hey
from the safety of our homes hey
hello uh welcome to
fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i am mark
bernardin
hey oh uh
how's everybody doing this fun evening i
mean
you better put on a happy face mark it's
stand up to cancer night
it is 100 stand up to cancer night and
my face is as happy as one face can be
after digging through a garage to put up
a christmas tree
and excavating all of that stuff because
you know every year you bury your
christmas tree way
deeper into the garage than you should
and every year i learned my lesson
the wrong way so i was tired
i'm doing none of that this year we're
going to see the kid in dallas for
christmas so we're not going to be here
so we didn't even get a tree this year
wow you win
it's crazy i mean i never thought i'd
become such a [ __ ] grinch in life
where i'm like ba
humbug christmas tree but the thought of
you know and i don't even do anything
all i do is go to the lot
pick it out and somebody brings the tree
and then
jennifer hangs the lights and then i
hang a quarter of the ornaments and then
that's it
but still it's i'm used to like two
decades almost in this house
of jennifer like being like i hate the
[ __ ] lights and i always have to
do the lights by myself nobody ever
helps me and stuff
so this year i'm like you ain't got no
lice to do man we're off like we're
gonna go
and then just earlier today jennifer was
just like i missed decorating for
christmas and i'm like
okay honey let's get a treat what uh
what did you finish decorating did you
finish three is the trees decorated yeah
because then and we got a fake tree
god at this point now 17 years because
we heard those stories
like when you have an infant like don't
get a real treat they could put their
pine needles in their mouths and it's
poison
and so we went and bought a fig tree and
now we love a fig tree
and so we've had the same one it's
almost old enough to drink
but uh raised on a fake tree man like it
wasn't until i got
married that i was uh forced to have
real trees she's a real big real treat
fan i've never had real trees growing up
me neither got a stick
and then you had branches that had color
coordinated either red or blue they
stuck into holes onto the stick
and it created a tree and then also we
went fancy in the smith house
my mom got like you know after christmas
sale at one point
a christmas tree holder
that turned shut up
yes so you would step on the button
click it
and then uh that would turn the lights
on
because it was all connected then you'd
step
on the clicker again and that would turn
that [ __ ] slowly around so
if you sat there you saw every side of
the
tree see but then you can't hide the
shitty side of the tree
um against the wall with fake trees
there is no shitty side
well if you keep it long enough
like why is this one a little tan well
it was next to the boiler sun
um i remember as a kid trying to lobby
my parents to get one of those crazy
like
let's get a blue tree let's get a silver
tree it's all metal
they would never let me all i ever
wanted was green and even
though trump you want a red tree blood
red
i wanted a full-on like tim burton
christmas and nobody would let me do it
and uh and even though now i am the
master of my own fate
i still feel like i can't do it that
would be betraying some chrisman
covenant
those trees are so i'm sorry i'm eating
the tums
those silver trees and [ __ ] like that
those are always portrayed as the glitzy
bad trees and like
christmas holiday specials like the
charlie brown christmas
that's why he kind of had one and [ __ ]
he stayed away from the
from the glam man yeah jolly brown has
soul so
i would just say you're as soulful as
charlie brown
i guess i want it to be as fabulous as
kiss though because i always imagine
like their christmas trees
it was [ __ ] like silver and black
with fire coming out the top and a
blood red would have to be blood pouring
down it right
oh yeah the demon doesn't just have your
regular ass christmas tree
um i'm sure there's a kiss christmas
tree you could buy
pre-lit with permits if i know anything
about gene simmons
there's absolutely a kiss christmas tree
because that dude merchandise is like
nobody's business
um speaking of comics stand up to cancer
ladies and gentlemen uh these good folks
uh let me read you some info today alone
4 949 people in the u.s will be
diagnosed
with cancer that's in addition to all
the covet numbers
but there is hope because right now
there are more than
uh 16.9 million cancer survivors
living in the united states man the
stand up
to cancer stream teams goal is to bring
together the content creator community
to raise awareness and funds to support
stand up to cancers groundbreaking
cancer research
a mission to end cancer as we know it
one stream at a time which sounds way
dirtier than i mean it but to most
kids you know who twitch that don't
sound dirty at all anymore but when
and mark its stream was when you took a
piss and you didn't cross the streams
man
yeah there were only two uses of stream
it was ghostbusters and it was urine
there you go stand-up cancer now has
1950 scientists involved
in current or past research funded by
stand up to cancer
nine cancer therapies approved by the
fda developed with support
of stand up to cancer research and
collaborating
with over 210 institutions stand up to
cancer
has raised over 600 million six i'm
i'm sorry six yeah no i was right 600
million
um dollars just in case you were like
million what hot dogs
uh for innovative cancer research
man yeah so we are we are hoping today
to make another 600 million dollars on
this stream
yes how to get there
is we're going to show you the [ __ ]
snyder cut
okay we're showing you the snyder cut
now man mark's got it he's going to play
it on his iphone hold it right up
and you're gonna see it and i just want
that money to come rolling in
man 600 million by the time we're done
we do not have a snyder cup to show you
ladies and gentlemen
yeah but we're hoping uh that to raise a
little money with the stream tonight
so uh no other sponsor it's just us
uh helping out the good folks stand up
to cancer who are helping out people
uh all over and doing the lord's work so
how do they donate
well i know there are links up on the
screen though
i'll jump in on that i know how they do
it
that's awesome um in the description of
uh if you're watching on youtube or
facebook
in the description uh you can find a
link and i'm also periodically posting
the link
in chat and if uh if you've always
wanted to be on fat man beyond
but never made it to scum villainy
cantina
if you donate you can see your your name
shows up
on the screen so that's
an easy way for you to get a cameo
on the show and ross mccartney just
donated 20 to fight cancer how do you
know that
because i see it on the feed look at
that well how about this man whoever
gives i mean look
everybody give that's awesome
periodically jc
will pop in and tell us like who's
given right jc can you be our tote board
can you be our
yeah we're doing well we've got these
people blah blah blah
i can jump in we've got uh a lot of
people so far
so i'll i'll i'll uh pick some of the
the bigger donors throughout the night
um
and can pop in and give them a shout out
that's
not to say that we don't appreciate the
little donors as jc was saying
right before we started the show if
everyone on the stream tonight
gave 50 cents we'd hit what
we feel our goal is we're going to try
to pull in 2 500 bucks that's what we
did
for [ __ ] um months back when we
did a stream uh yeah to support comic
book stops
yeah so how about that we'll put a we'll
put a loose goal of 2 500 bucks for
tonight
2 500 bucks for stand up to cancer who's
gonna do it if not
you who's gonna do you
you lieutenant weinberg you want me on
that wall
you need to be on that one um all right
so stand up
cancer uh is who's uh
well they're not sponsoring the show but
no we're doing the show just like
yes this show is for them this is all
for that man
this is for the stand up the stand up to
cancer
um all right throughout the night jc
will pop in
let us know how we're doing there total
wise and the big
uh the generous gifters and stuff like
that anybody who gives is generous
uh but uh before we get into
the news what not um
did you get your copy i didn't get my
copy yes
this ladies and gentlemen is smartest in
residence
it is the new book by that young
gentleman
nate gonzalez and if you're like well
that he looks familiar that looks
familiar
is because nate is the gentleman who's
responsible
for all the artwork that sells all the
shows
we ever do um i have this on a shirt
he is the smartest in residence
in the title and he's here with us right
now
to talk about his book man uh welcome
to normally he sits in the audience of
this show as we've been doing it for
years and whatnot but in quarantine
there's no audience and stuff
but uh he is always even if he's even if
he's not in the audience when we
do our shows solo at the cantina
um he's in literally every show because
he does
the artwork every week that promotes the
[ __ ] show and in most cases
i see higher praise for the artwork that
promotes the show
than the [ __ ] show ladies and
gentlemen welcome
to fat man beyond the man who's
responsible for selling
fat man beyond every week nate gonzalez
i do i do part of the selling
there's also you know the man at the
very back yeah this is my first time
as a participant finally uh you know
after watching
all this time i get to finally jump in
and watch old fam ambiance and
you pipe back i know what you're right
i'm back you're right i haven't popped
up
yeah you were you and you would you
would correct me and stuff not in a
shitty way but you would be like i did i
saw this
um nate you have this book
uh it's a wonderful book whoever helped
you get it made is a [ __ ] genius
you uh did a super special edition
of uh 25 copies that were signed by like
me you mark
ralph jay all the people depicted in the
book and they
sold out just like that now you're
selling uh another hundred um
and it's the standard edition it's
signed by me and you
and it comes with the original
lithograph that you made just for the
book and we sign a number
um where where's the
you can go to thedarknatereturns.com
it's pretty simple it should be the
first
uh product or if you just want to go
directly to the product itself you can
go to bit
dot ly slash smartest book that's
s-m-a-r-t-i-s-t
book dot uh no dot com just bit l-y
smartest book right there on the screen
as you can see
um it's a gorgeous yeah thank you
they're selling quick so
you know better hurry before uh you know
the deadline to get it in for christmas
too
that's coming quick but uh they should
be shipping out the regular editions
are shipping out next week and i think
some people are already getting the
special editions
uh in hand so it's exciting people are
starting to get to actually see the
physical uh product
very nice what is it like seeing all
your
work between two covers
and like in it somewhere either in the
the intro or on the back of the book you
say like
uh how many pieces how many years
it's just about two years uh you know
january
would be the like two year mark of
officially working first mod co like
being brought in and stuff but
that first poster right there that was
october of 2018
so yeah just over two years since the
whole poster
trend began how did this happen tell the
kids
yeah the secret origin stuff like where
how did this wind up happening
that's a very very good question because
i do these things i don't really take
note
of how they start i just you know make
something online or i make a
turn on photoshop and i like to treat
photoshop just like a blank canvas and
you can start with basically anything
and um
i don't know i think i was just inspired
by the idea that every
episode of the show is like an episode
or like a comic issue
in itself there's individuality to each
and every episode and
uh i've just always been a fan of um
making art that not only just encaptures
like
what the what the feel of the thing that
i'm you know
representing is but something that also
makes it feel like it's a part of a
universe
like it tells a story part of a bigger
picture and that's what i like about
smodco events is that they always have a
sort of uh
connected feel to it because you're
always referencing the other
things that are happening in your life
and then i think the second
factor of that motivation was i've
always been
surrounded by other people's art um
going to comic-con
since i was young i think i made a point
every year to stop at artist ali
and buy somebody's print buy a print
from somebody patronize some artist
and i think a couple times i found some
stuff that was kevin smith related but
more times i would go on ebay and find
like
old kevin smith q a evening with kevin
smith posters and i'd buy those up
and i'd have them all over my room and i
think i would just sort of osmo
by osmosis inherit these ideas of like
you know here's kevin smith he's an
entity that
is advertised in a certain way he has
clearly he has a style that he likes to
advertise himself in
um so i think that just went with that i
just rolled with this idea that um
you have already a pretty uh
pretty easy brand to tap into and to uh
you know i don't want to say exploit but
uh
you know just really focus on and you
it's pretty easy to make a kevin smith
friendly piece i found
what um were you [ __ ] around with art
much before
all this um i started in
junior year of high school i took a
graphic design class
and i took to photoshop like really
really quickly so fast that like i was
done with the lessons before
you know the teacher was you know done
explaining it to the rest of the class
so i would just dick around and make
like
really shitty office like the office
memes and
quotes of like arrested development and
stuff like that um
but then i would also start doing like
event posters for
the plays that like the drama department
put on there was like a sadie hawkins
dance that was
nerd themed so i made this uh like a
star trek themed poster so it's stuff
like that that like especially in school
i was only interested in like
creative things that sparked me like
that drove me to actually make something
versus just making a paper
or writing like some sort of you know
educational piece but um i
after high school i think i only took
like one other graphic design class and
community college
but otherwise i pretty much just [ __ ]
around on photoshop on my own
for a couple of years making either like
yeah event posters for
like a couple of local theater things um
but it was really just a hobby at first
it was really just like you know this is
something i'm good at this is something
i like doing
and um just something that's in my back
pocket as a sort of jack-of-all-trades
thing i originally wanted to be a writer
i thought i could
you know get my toe into that world and
make a difference but it's hard there's
a lot of competition for writing
i don't know if you guys know this um
i've heard it's a tough racket
but uh let me tell you something it's
it reminds me of george carlin who
wanted to be an actor and then backed
into comedy
mk yeah [ __ ] brilliant and [ __ ] and
you're like
what do you mean you like there's a guy
who was like well i wanted to do this
and you're like
you [ __ ] became the king of that he's
like yeah
that the door is never closed i mean one
day i would like to write a screenplay i
would like to
i like my ambition really was to be
another stephen king and just write a
book read movies write tv
do something of everything um but i
found that like making posters
oftentimes i could tell i could tap into
the storyteller in me or um at least the
parts of myself that appreciate the
story of like the movie that i'm making
the poster on
or um or i'm basing the poster on in the
sense of
batman beyond because i take so many
pastiches and make parodies of
uh other stuff but beyond like the
artwork that nate does for the show if
you go to like his site you'll see
he does artwork uh based on like a bunch
of stuff has nothing to do with me or
any of the podcast
movies that he likes and stuff and he's
right he does
like the people at mondo he finds a
different way in
to the poster than the poster world
rusev
it's the alternative movie poster
community i guess is what you would call
it
and it is a community man like it's very
much true very huge on twitter
um so kids out there listening he was
just [ __ ] around with
photoshop and now he's a published
author and stuff but the
middle point is how do you remember
how it went from you were in the
audience to me going
oh can i use your artwork to sell the
show
when did that definitely definitely
helps that you're as active on twitter
as you are because i think it took a
couple of times i mean ultimately it was
um the first time i ever met you at the
jan salabab
groovy movie uh vip thing um
i wasn't even like i was barely a
digital or graphic artist at that point
so
it wasn't really until like i think a
year or two after that that i started
making art related to you
and the first thing was the edge of
vacation pub quiz
that was i think the first time i ever
made anything from scratch for you or
not from sky i made that bad news bears
poster and i always think about it as
in the office at michael's last episode
where he gives oscar that like
that doll and it cuts to him laughing
his ass off because he's like
he accepted that thing and it looked
like a monkey made it like and that's
how i felt about that piece at the time
like comparatively to where i am now i
feel like i've come such a long way
towards you know my own style and and
perfecting the idea of parroting
something else
um but yeah it was the pub quiz that i
think i did a lot of the earliest part
for
and then that got me into the the uh the
fat man door
uh and then i think it was just hanging
out at the alleyway out after the show
um because before that we had already we
already kind of knew each other it
sounds so [ __ ] dirty
about like all it takes yeah hanging
around by the alleyway
you can show these two get off stage
they're looking to wind down
they're looking to unload do you need uh
the point here kids is talon else
um you know nate was always a wonderful
member
a member of the audience but like you
know
suddenly he had this hidden flare or
more importantly he had this thing that
could be exploited
as they said where i was like oh my god
[ __ ] i need art
i'll pay you for [ __ ] art and [ __ ]
like that um and it's been a
beneficial like relationship um i've
you know i i i when you're an
entertainer
i you know i see i read a lot of people
are seeing people like oh i hate
watching my
[ __ ] i don't know if i buy that man
because like you can't be
in this business without like a degree
of self love
that's unknown that's like not
like everyone else's healthy degree of
self-love a degree of like oh man i
[ __ ] really like kevin smith
so when you see yourself rendered like
you know it's still
flattering i don't know i don't know who
doesn't get flattered by that
and you render me and my friends
in fun engaging [ __ ] catchy ways like
if i wasn't a
watcher or you know a host if i wasn't a
host of [ __ ] fat man beyond and i saw
that artwork
like that would make me tune in i'd be
like that's [ __ ] i don't know it's
got something
and it's very identifiable now
like for us as kind of a house style but
like
you know it's it's nate style
um i don't know i'm damned impressed uh
mark um i will say that on
uh perhaps to the contrary i do not have
that level of self-love enough to want
to see myself a whole lot
uh i'll give you the debbie allen and
fame speech right now
name is you know it requires sweat it
requires sweat
and so uh but but i will say that even
as a person who
does not like looking at themselves that
much
i do not mind looking at myself on the
covers of
batman beyond posters because they are
pushed just enough
very often nate is incredibly kind to my
waistline
um he managed to shave off a chin or two
um so it's uh that as well he does that
to me too
i know what you mean but i i'm so
very humbled and grateful that you guys
humor me as many times as you have
because i mean there have rarely been
times where i'll send something to kevin
and he's like
no i don't i don't dig that like you're
very very generous with
you know what you what you accept from
me so i'm always thankful
i'm like well i don't like that it's
usually like let's use that next week
but let's do something
about this this week because generally
like that hold it
and you have great detail like you have
a great eye for detail too especially
when it comes to like you always give me
that like
ad copy notes about let's move the text
down there or let's make it smaller
uh so you know it's very likely that if
you have a piece
of mind that you like like a lot that
has something to do with kevin there's a
good chance that he has like a small
piece of input in it so
editorial oversight meanwhile i'm just
always blissfully surprised like oh
that's cool
yeah uh um one of the new one the purple
grain
artwork we had we you know printed up a
bunch of prints for the minneapolis
movies that opens uh next weekend i
guess
and uh so we printed up the posters and
i signed a whole pile but i was like i'm
taking this one [ __ ] home
i'm getting a frame for the house it's
[ __ ] good me and jay
it took two of us to take the space of
apollonia i thought that was jesus
um nate give him one more time where
they can find the book books
only 50 copies left at this point
dot l y slash smartest book
that's b i t dot l y slash
s m a r t i s t
b o o uh or just thedarknatereturns.com
if you can't remember all that uh you
can find me at the dark nate returns on
instagram
or at darkmate returns on twitter and
uh yeah that's pretty pretty that
concludes my
my first and only publicity thought on
this tour
sadly it's not good morning america but
you know um
i'm more of a today person we'll get
jane paulie out of retirement to talk to
you
what is is that a sign julie newmar
photo beside you
yeah it says you are perfect
it's adorable there it is ladies and
gentlemen the smartest
in residence nate we all love you thank
you goodbye
thank you guys thank you nate bye bye
bye
uh what a good dude and what a great
artist
yeah i remember when like i can't
remember the exact moment when nate came
into my life
except that there was a text chain that
suddenly he was on
and i was like kev is he working for you
now
when we do the show yeah and you're like
yeah now he's doing the posters
okay cool i was like he's your boss now
[Laughter]
let's go um
minneapolis movies opens uh
saturday i believe it is december 12th
kids but
that doesn't mean go see it it's all
like we sold
you guys sold this out the whole first
week um i think there's like
40 slots left in the very last day of
the extension
we went until they extended it by like
three days to december
22nd um but that's
that like yeah i can't even like send
you there like go because if you don't
have a reservation
you don't get in but thank you to
everybody out there in
minneapolis man that was really sweetie
um i also have
i'm gonna pop in before we go any
further we already hit our goal
are you kidding me less than 30 minutes
into the show we're at
2573 dollars how crazy is that
everybody have a great weekend our work
here is not
going home i'm gonna go catch saturday
live in real time goodbye everybody
wow that's awesome thank you to the
whole [ __ ] audience for uh
amazing that's great we'll keep it going
man if that's if that's
you now we can make that much in the
same amount of time let's just keep the
show going for like four hours and see
what happens
um let me do some shout outs here
because we've got like eight pages of
games
uh these are getting us to that number
sophia
l lot norm donated a hundred dollars
uh classy hellion uh 37
appropriately uh seriously nas says [ __ ]
cancer for 25 dollars amen that's the
sentiment of the evening isn't it [ __ ]
cancer hard
uh well hard that it likes it [ __ ]
poorly like [ __ ] it a little and then
back off like you're done and then
cancer's like are you [ __ ] kidding me
and you're like
yeah i can't i'm sorry i finished early
and then you walk out of the room
that's what you do to cancer because
[ __ ] is too good for cancer but
anyway
stand up to it you can do that as well
uh mr mrs hodgdon
said they lost two mothers last year to
cancer kevin thanks so much for this we
are huge fans
oh that's beautiful hey amy joe green
donated
fifty dollars says uh let's kill it
cancer took my mom this year
well three neighbors like amy jo green
she may indeed kill it because as we
know most serial killers
only have three names and amy joe green
sounds like
john wayne i'm looking for i'm looking
for the elusive four names here the
killer
yeah that ain't happening not in our
lifetime
uh but if anyone's gonna kill cancer
it's gonna be her
rob smith 97 donated 50 caleb p
donated 50 dollars nice uh i said
dance kids you took me way too seriously
50 bucks very kind
kyle riser 40 in memory of grandma rest
in peace
um what's up
kyle reese kyle reiser
oh oh yeah not the time travel not the
time travel
uh oh my god somebody somebody [ __ ]
listen to him
he's got an important message he lost
his grandma kyle reiser did kyle reiser
did
sorry man that breaks my heart that's
not bad baby yoda
donated 25 uh there are no basically
elements here there's only grogu
this is the way baby dj kento donated
sixty nine dollars
he says sixty dollars i have the sexiest
donation of the night
says uh i love you guys kevin you got me
through some tough times
mark you've opened up my eyes and jc i
can't make to finally meet you
and come to the cantina right on man how
kind
uh rico l 50 says [ __ ]
cancer uh [ __ ] it indeed rico
glassmaker 540 gave ten dollars and says
do what you can when you can
which i thought was so true again folks
we're
no pressure we were talking about 50
cents a person so
what you're doing is wonderful above and
beyond a lot of you
uh hillary nicole donated fifty dollars
and uh that's the first me
skimming the first three pages so i'll
pop back on in a little bit and
uh and uh keep going that's beautiful
this is to you fat man beyond audience
y'alls is the best a nice drink of water
um that's great man that's fantastic
i like that people put up their stories
too i'm like
so you know it's one thing to just put
up a donation it's another thing but
like here's my money and here's why
like oh i love that [ __ ] um
i uh am doing something tomorrow night
online um i'm doing i got two things
coming up
one is i'm busy
i'm quarantined busy um
one is uh tomorrow night there's a
screening of freaky
the vince vaughn movie um that i'm gonna
be doing a
watch along on twitter uh i think that's
it
is the time listed there i think it's
five o'clock pst eight o'clock
pst i watched the movie today [ __ ]
fun man
yeah yeah there wasn't a freaky friday
kind of thing it i mean it
like they're not even trying to hide it
absolutely the working title was freaky
friday the 13th
nice so they eventually just went with
freaky but uh
the guy who directed it um is
michael landon's kid
yes isn't that weird i was like because
i'm i'm like this is [ __ ] good man
this is
assuredly directed who [ __ ] did what
kid did this
he's not a kid he's [ __ ] older than
me um
it's uh i think his name is christopher
landon
um is it my jc can you check on that i'm
pretty sure that's the name
but i love christopher it's christopher
i looked him up and he's michael
landon's youngest yeah isn't that crazy
yeah he wrote disturbia years ago
and shia la and then uh he's taken it
directing lately writing and directing
he did
um happy death day
apparently they had senses of humor to
him i'm gonna watch happy update
tomorrow because
i thought freaky was [ __ ] fun man i
enjoy the [ __ ] out of it
um and it's like you know it's because
it's a premise like i was telling my
wife and she's like i'm gonna watch that
and i was like i'll watch it by myself
and i did and i was like you missed out
because it wasn't what you thought it
was
like it was adorable for a [ __ ]
bloody movie and it was
[ __ ] bloody man like he's got five
six kills in the movie which is straight
out of like you know
friday the 13th or [ __ ] halloween
like 80s gory plastic
what looked like practical effects if
they weren't practical
boy they're [ __ ] even better than i
thought but he killed people
he wasn't afraid to kill people all like
[ __ ] up and fun and [ __ ] the whole
thing's got like a
sense of humor to it it's really well
done man um so anyway we're gonna
do a watch along tomorrow night at five
on twitter
join us there and then i don't know when
this
airs but on monday me and
danny fernandez you know danny who was
with us on
the crisis aftermath show she co-hosted
a black man beyond
with me yes and that as well and she's
got a life beyond us
of course but that's just yes the
audience here we are just holding her
star down
totally this is [ __ ] we've been
holding her back now you're gonna watch
her rise and i'm gonna be right there
when it happens
um we're co-hosting the
uh critics choice super awards
i believe it's paul is that the title
for it
sounds about right let me just double
check but it's uh
it's an awards ceremony from the
people's
critics choice not people's choice hold
on
critics not even critics choice jesus
i'm getting it all wrong
critics superhero awards
um we shoot that
on monday me and danny and i'm not sure
when it airs but when it airs
it airs on cw critics superhero awards
so
it's it's exactly that it's the
genre awards given by critics but not to
like
the you know the normal fare
specifically
to genres elevating genre stuff really
kind of sweet idea
so go ahead
i wish that existed when i was still a
critic that sounds awesome
i wish it existed when i was a [ __ ]
kid man just to be able to like one
award show i wouldn't have been dragged
to as a child in front of the
old globes are on i'm like oh who cares
we're never going to see darth vader
we're never going to see david prowse
it's natalie we're going to ever see
david prowse again i'm sure he's in our
news tonight isn't he
that was last week sir oh my god [ __ ]
i've lost time
god has it already been a week since
david brown passed away
it was monday we did a show monday night
yeah oh that's right it's been a short
[ __ ] week
um all right uh so yes uh i'm not sure
when the
critics the critics superhero awards
critics superhero awards are not my
title are airing but uh we're shooting
them
on monday very cool uh so it sounds fun
yeah
yeah it'll be it'll be interesting what
do you got going on
um dude not much of anything you know
it's
it's it has bank no
is matt good here i'm gonna read you my
favorite moment in the movie
favorite line um so there's
there's a moment where louis b mayer i
think it is
excuse me um is
walking with mangowitz uh down the um
lot he's like walk with me and they go
walking down the the lot at mgm
and he's just holding forth as a studio
head
he says this line ready this is a
business where the buyer gets nothing
for his money but a memory
what he bought still belongs to the man
who sold it
that's the real magic of the movies and
don't let anybody tell you different
you you know you want to watch that
[ __ ] now i know i want to watch that
no no then it is honestly if the if it
doesn't win best screenplay
i don't i you know there's no justice
it's insanely well written
um feels like a spiritual sequel as you
would imagine too
citizen kane incredibly shot
insanely well directed [ __ ] score
sounds like a period score
even though it's you know composed to
have come back
right like trent [ __ ] resner and
atticus rox
um the cast is top-notch like
it's it's a great [ __ ] journey but
you know the only
downside is instantly it makes you want
to watch citizen keynes that's not
really a downside but i've seen citizen
key
so it was [ __ ] good that's worth
watching but you suggested something to
me
last week what was it because i think i
watched it
wayne no but i just watched the trailer
for wayne today and i showed it to jen
she's like i'm not watching that i was
like i'll watch it alone
um there was something else that you
liked to give a shout out to
um queen's gambit well we had already
talked about that
last week i forget what it was but i did
i did watch something this week that was
at your best or your suggestion it
turned out to be good
um i don't remember what i said to you
as mank i'm telling you you'll [ __ ]
you'll really dig it like the writing
is i feel like it's going to be like a a
citizen kane bank double feature
because it's like i've seen citizen kane
a few times before but it's been
probably about
15 20 years um so i'm probably overdue
long overdue a rewatch
um the thing i'm crazy curious about and
and i never thought i would say this but
did you see the trailers for the
godfather coda
the death of milanko corleone
francis or coppola went in and like
re-cut godfather three
yeah yeah and uh talking about doing it
there's a trailer for it already there's
a trailer for it already which you know
granted there's no new footage
it's not like he assembled the cast
again at great expense to to paramount
for a 70 million dollar reshoot of the
godfather three
um but you know there was an injury from
him released the coppola cup
but it's very i mean couple is all about
the kabbalah cut
um but yeah there's a little intro from
him on it just talking about like yeah
we always
envision this as less a godfather three
and more just an
end to the story of michael corleone
from god's father's one and two like
it's not really supposed to be
its own different adventure and so he
recut it he
like i think they might have rescored
parts of it um
and i'm just i'm curious man like i i
i i do not remember liking godfather
three that much
um because they suffered from the same
way that so many things suffer for
not being as good as some of the best
movies ever made but probably
pretty okay but the the plumbing and
quality was so severe that everybody
kind of [ __ ] all over it well the
problem was you had
just like with phantom menace you had a
long
time to appreciate this two movies that
came look
i'm i'm about to face the same stupid
thing myself
and it's my own my own stupid fault next
year if we do make twilight of the mall
rats people love
mall rats for 25 years and then i come
along and i'm like
let me show you more rats too
you know would have been a low bar if we
made the sequel in 96
now in 2020 it's a high [ __ ] bar man
same thing
happened with godfather three was we had
years to love those two movies and you
know
pore over them and they were absolutely
[ __ ] groundbreaking genius films
and then all of a sudden you know years
after the fact they were like we're
gonna go again
and so people were like oh it's gonna be
as good
as one and two and you know
it's not that it wasn't as good as one
and two it just wasn't
one and two yeah to like um know [ __ ]
damn it cinematically and then on top of
it people went after his kid which i
honestly always thought she was fine in
the movie
i i in a way i thought she was actually
kind of
good like you know not would you
would winona ryder the original uh
actor cast have been better yeah
yeah winona ryder is a genius but like
everyone made sophia cobble out to be
like terrible
movies she's not she's just not winona
ryder
so i never had as much of a problem
with the flick um but like just like
when i went into phantom menace i wasn't
like
this is gonna make me feel like star
wars and empire made me feel
of course not this was like years later
so
my i kept my bar low for that reason but
godfather three helped me
keep the bar low you know that was one
of those movies where you're like
you know whenever when it came out and
everyone was jumping on it and [ __ ]
on it
it wasn't until a year or two later when
like i was watching it going like what
happened this
ain't bad like [ __ ] is actually
pretty decent yeah it's hard to like
discreetly judge these things right
where it's
because i was i was talking to somebody
about you know
i i don't even know why but we're
talking about game of thrones
and the finale compared to the rest of
the show and it's like you know
the the finale's not great the last
season's not great but it's also not
horrible either it's just good
as seasons one through five you know and
it's it's hard
to divorce those two things from each
other you know
once you that the plunge is what ruins
it
not the landing you don't notice where
the landing is we're like oh it still
landed in like the eb plus territory it
just wasn't all a pluses across the
board the way it was before
excellent [ __ ] definitely
i've got some godfather three uh
knowledge gossip
about why it ended up the way it did
i believe that walter merge who was the
editor on
the godfather movies and the
conversation he was coppola's editor
wrote in a book oh 20
some odd 30 some odd years ago that the
movie was supposed to be initially about
robert
duvall's character and robert duvall
wanted so much money that coppola told
him to
f off basically i was
the person who got you in who made your
career
and now you're going to do me dirty like
this forget it
and so they changed the entire movie
because of
robert duvall's attitude problem and i
remember
that tom hayden was tom hagan was
originally a bigger part like i remember
i didn't hear that they fought but i
remember at one point he was supposed to
be a part of it
because he was back when they made
godfather one and two
uh he played tom hagan the consigliere
and stuff
and as jc said koppel absolutely made
his career
but you know when they went and made
godfather three
uh robert duvall was huge he was at that
point in his career
where he was getting that in life work i
mean he always worked consistently
this was a great santini for urban sex
but he was also like at another career
resurgence where he was getting like big
jobs
and it was kind of unsettling that he
wasn't in godfather three because you're
like
what happened to tom and they i think
they kill him like off camera or he just
died they mentioned something about him
dying or something yeah
it wouldn't have been this bad for you
if tom hadn't just died or something
like that
but yeah it's it's always funny when you
hear about the the path that these
movies wanted to take but couldn't for
some reason
you know like i i remember hearing that
uh that terminator salvation
not ever going to be as good as the
alpha 3 was going to be
but was a very different movie before
christian bale signed on to play john
connor
like is john connor was supposed to be a
cameo like the movie is about
this this other terminator that doesn't
know is a terminator and is trying to
find itself and the
missing link between human and machine
was the same worthington character and
then bail sends on
and bell's a movie star and bell's like
well i want this to be about john connor
and so the script begins to warp and
twist
and bend in ways that structurally can't
really support
similar because you get a movie star who
wants to be the star of the movie
and like that that feeling of there's a
version of this that is the
destined version and then the version
you get because of casting
and budgets and negotiations and all
that stuff that can adversely affect the
movie itself
um you take john connor out of salvation
i don't know there's much there to
much there to enjoy yeah i mean i
i don't know but i think that there's
it's definitely
absolutely right i agree with you though
but by him coming in they were like oh
my god now we can beef up this part
yeah but like the story wasn't built for
that and
although not to not like swing in here
while we're raising money for cancer and
[ __ ] on the terminator movies but
um even the good ones are all basically
remakes of the first one
where it's hey here's this lady who
doesn't know what her life is going to
be
oh here's these things who come back
from time who tell her who her life is
going to be
and terminators slide each other and a
rebel guy
from the future comes back to the past
because he has a personal connection
with the protagonist
like well it works but it's all the same
thing
um that at least would have been
different
and still was different but not it's the
x3
of uh of terminator movies it was it
could have been different but it was
different
that's different yeah a little strange
yeah not that strange
all right shall we dive in we can dive
in man
and and there there are two stories that
feel like
there's mark nardin over there he's the
newsman he's about to give you the news
man
pull down your news pants because you're
about to get news slapped
across the ass by mr mark bernard
um do we want to talk mando first we
want to hop right into news
let us talk [ __ ] mando man like
uh this was a huge episode
for so many reasons um both uh
just as a star wars fan and personally
as well
the return of boba fett and not just the
return
but ladies and gentlemen have you met
boba fett
they finally same way rogue one showed
you the like the best
vader you've ever seen
mandalorian just showed us the best boba
fett we've ever seen
and shown why he's a galactic badass
i mean all that faith has been rewarded
that anybody all these years carrying a
torch for boba fett
was just like i knew anyone with a boba
fett tattoo right now is wearing it a
little more proudly
because he just [ __ ] kills people
with gaffy sticks
and goes just [ __ ] crazy wearing his
armor and man
you know he's got old man punched to him
which was pretty dead i was so
happy about that he gets his armor back
on is just a little bit underneath there
it's like yeah i pulled on those pants
that don't fit before i
i feel you boba yeah um yeah that was
amazing
but um
my boy shot it i know so
dave climb baby dave klein the kid who
shot
clerks all those years ago mall rats
chasing amy
and then clerks ii zach and mary
and cop out with me um he's done many
many things he
he did uh you know homeland for almost
this entire run and
true blood and stuff like that but there
he is
shooting star wars from from shooting
kids in a convenience store talking
about star wars
to literally shooting [ __ ] boba
fett's return himself
man like it was amazing as i watched the
episode
i was like holy [ __ ] i mean i you know i
know what he's capable of he's
always been graded red state red state's
an amazing movie
um as i watched it i just
like felt like giddy
because i'm like i you know i know these
k
you know it's not many not very often
you can watch your favorite thing
and some of your favorite people aren't
involved in it at least not in my world
so it was it was really [ __ ] sweet
that's back to back
clerk's two refugees you know
in the last episode and then dave kline
in this episode
and watching the kid
get taken away by the dark troopers like
was [ __ ] heartbreaking but also
tragedy at least there's some
forward momentum which i'm sure you have
something to say about it i was so happy
that this episode ended with
with us not getting you know who you
should see mendo
this name on this planet and he says
okay
here we go on to the razer crest and
away we go
um it was it was nice for for the plot
lines that we
started to tease this entire season to
kind of begin to come together
you know like guardians mouth gideon
he's got a thing that he wants to know
[ __ ] dark troopers are coming here and
oh the
jedi go to the put him on the rock the
sending rock and the seeing rock
whatever and he'll
he'll put his force out into the
universe and somebody will find him
who's it going to be
i don't know we'll find out later but
there seems to be a convergence of stuff
and some progress of stuff
so that's right they put the kid on the
rock because that would beam them out
like professor x style and
would pick up on it and then they
stole the kid the bad guy stole the kid
and took off so
i'm it's so weird like you're like i'm a
storyteller too and i didn't even piece
this together and you just said it out
loud
they've like there's probably a jedi
coming
yes there's probably at some point if i
had to guess
episode eight of season two a jedi is
going to show up
um do you think this season
don't you think that's a thing that you
could i mean because what episode they
are now when do they stop
um i mean this was episode five of of
this season and i think they go eight
right jason am i right or is it four j.c
where are we
in six this is
uh so this was chapter
14 so this was six so we only have two
left
yeah we have two left so i bet you we're
not going to see
the jedi this season maybe there's a
tease at the last
episode but that sounds like something
you
string over to season three i'd imagine
but i
totally spaced on the fact that like oh
my god that's right
they just sent uh essentially a call out
into the universe so somebody's gonna
become looking for that kid one of the
good guys
um how many people want to bet
that the dark saber
and the vest spear
are going to cross got it right it's the
only thing that survived the destruction
of the razor crest
spoilers kids hopefully everybody's
watched the episode already
spoilers but you know it's [ __ ]
saturday
and the thing's been up 24 hours so
and who are you if you haven't and if
you're on and if you're watching this
show
come on yeah if you're strapping in on a
saturday night
to listen to us talk about [ __ ] i mean
not to gatekeep
but i'm pretty sure you're also the kind
of person who who was up midnight on
thursday being like yes
it's streaming here we go this is the
way it was it was a beautiful [ __ ]
experience
and rodriguez robert rodriguez shut the
hell out of it
oh as always um robert there's things
that i always forget because
you know i i love the robert rodriguez
and desperado
and now mariachi um i less love the
robert rodriguez of elita battle angel
like i less love
all of that just it's all cg and it's
all whatever
watching him just do a [ __ ] shootout
like let's have ming now win shoot
98 stormtroopers in new and interesting
ways like
he's really good at that he's just
really good at practical
first boba armor reveal shot you know
the stormtrooper turns around
he's got him just high over him he's all
big and badass
that's pure robert robert he goes man
and then the [ __ ]
last shot that he does where he takes
out the trooper
i loved his knee cannons i thought that
[ __ ] rocked when he put his knee up
um yeah man it's it's continues to be
crazy good tv uh
it's spellbinding like you know you
thought
how are they going to [ __ ] how do you
how do you get over something as big as
ahsoka
and look at that yeah it's crazy
so who knows what the [ __ ] they're gonna
do
for the next two episodes like
there's an escalation and now with the
kid
like being now it's they're all gonna
cross paths they gotta
yeah i mean go to the episode after and
i mean it feels like yeah i mean it's
boba and ming
wen and and jin jardine or whatever his
name is
which again his name is den i
never called him din he's always gonna
be mando i don't care if you give a name
he's mando
um but you know the three amigos going
off to chase a baby into outer space
yeah i'm here for that um who's the
the comedian that bill burr looks like
he's coming back next week because they
looked up his picture
right he went to see cara dune and she
was like oh this guy
so he figures in next week somehow but i
don't think we will see a jedi this year
i mean there's there's the version where
the last shot of episode eight is
another [ __ ] lightsaber
you know and or something to that effect
um somebody
somebody's stepping on that rock you
know where they were
on python which is i believe the first
live-action depiction of tython the jedi
homeworld usually that's like
it's from the books and the extended
universe maybe the games or something
like that
right but this is the first time they've
ever done it in a [ __ ] thing
live action so yeah there's there's the
here's the end of the
it's the kicker into season three or
it's a thing that comes deeper into
into season three hoping you remember
and they absolutely can guarantee that
the fans will remember
oh that's right he sent up a beacon and
somebody's going to answer that beacon
and who's it going to be is it going to
be ezra bridges is it going to be
[ __ ] luke skywalker is it going to be
jar jar oh is it going to be jar jar
amen in a world where this show has the
ability to
like [ __ ] rehabilitate any character
any character think about what we just
saw with boba fett
wait is jar jar still alive at this
point in saga
he would be alive he would be alive
be amazing if they [ __ ] like
rehabilitated [ __ ] jar jar they're
like we're taking them back
and like turned him into a [ __ ]
killer badass killer [ __ ]
now this is this is post it post
um return the jedi right five years
after return of the jedi five you just
have to return the jedi okay
this part of me was like if it's early
enough then you could always
use the which jedi is going to answer is
obi-wan kenobi and then you kick off
into the kenobi show but
no that timeline doesn't work out yeah
he's dead
he's dead by now my money's on ezra
bridger
from rebels i would put all my money on
ezra bridger
for rebels yeah really
because of the circuit connection yeah
because of the ahsoka connection
from the end of the show and the felony
connection i think they might save
him for like either next season or the
ahsoka show
i think if they're like if they throw
the word jedi out
um you know and we've seen ahsoka and
that's not
most cats in the world who like star
wars didn't know that she was a
character a
or b a jedi i think if they're saying
jedi they got to show you someone
that you we recognize as a jedi and at
that point
in the universe there aren't many left
right it's luke
it's ahsoka
ezra
leia because we learned she was being
trained at that time
sadly she's not coming uh
that would be amazing if they did you
know what i'm saying like just
i mean just just do it i mean at some
point you're going to recast
for young princess leia
in the end like this would not be jedi
that would be jedi leia they'd be
yeah years after the after the bathing
suit essentially
a lot of people in there a lot of people
in the chat are saying mace windu guys
it's not going to be me
well he dies doesn't it he dies in in at
the end of sit
well so does darth maul but that's
people
yeah i say it's the spirit of qui-gon i
say they got liam neeson
could you imagine i mean what's like why
look liam neeson did a voice in the
[ __ ] lego movie right
so like i can't imagine nathan likes to
get paid
and also just like like hey man come
hang out you don't have to spend as much
time as you spent doing phantom menace
but like
we need you to force ghost it and [ __ ]
whatever oh it'd be amazing
although if you told me that sam jackson
was going to come back as like old mace
windu
who didn't actually die like suddenly
giant nerd boner he also has an age
since 1999
on earth so it would work wait a second
but in the timeline even if he hadn't
gotten killed
by the emperor this would then be
40 30 years later he'd be like 75
yeah 75 or 80.
so which bottom you pull it off yeah i
mean it's like if alex gimmick can you
know hobble around
as a jedi at how old was he like
75 when he got star wars he was mark
hamill's
age when mark did episode eight
is what i heard was that sixty something
yeah
wow we care for our skin so much better
these days
we've got to be more clever about who
we're thinking with jedi's
it's got to be something we're not
seeing
can i say my favorite part of the show
and the thing that really
stuck out to me is that uh
hazlab the hasbro like special order toy
uh company where they do like crowd
funding where
hey if we sell six thousand of java's
sail barge will make the giant jabba
sail barge
just sold 28 278
star wars the vintage collection razor
crest toys
like three months ago and now
it is exploded
how pissed would you be if you were like
i finally got the like new millennium
falcon
and they're like nope like if you're a
handles bro
i don't get to play the first 12
chapters
oh i don't know i mean they blew up the
enterprise more than once and they
always built another enterprise
um it's true i didn't even think about
the fact that like
there's so much going on in that episode
they also blew up the [ __ ] razor
crest
what is he gonna do i guess he's in
slave one for a while but what happens
next season i guess we'll find out
well i'm telling you man like they just
here's razor crest too
back from the dead and then
he just screws the ball right back on
where it's supposed to be
and like here's the new one how adorable
was the opening where he kept saying
grow goo
go yeah and he's laughing
yeah just dug out much like this [ __ ]
kid knows his name
another amazing episode and uh
two more two more left this season and
then our world goal is cold and dark
again
for a bit yeah at least until january
15th when apparently one division
is going to premiere is that when it
starts that's that's the rumor
january 15th i'm in i'm in for that
all right what news we got dude the news
of the week
um bar none above and beyond was
warner brothers decision to premiere
their entire 2021 slate
on hbo max this was news so big that we
texted each other to be like holy [ __ ]
yeah like oh god like i mean we thought
that there were going to be more things
and last week we were talking about
godzilla versus kong
and you know water brothers kind of
putting the kibosh on a big offer from
netflix to premiere
streaming on that service i'm like well
they're probably going to put it on hbo
max because wonder woman seems to be a
thing they're doing so
why wouldn't they do that did not see it
coming that they were just going to put
every movie on hbo max how many movies
um let's see at least
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 movies so that's their entire
2021 slate the retired 21 theatrical
slate
is going to premiere an hbo max and it's
going to follow the same pattern as
wonder woman 84 which is
you will get it for a month but also
premiere theatrically as well and
promote theatrically wherever you can go
to a theater
um but uh and then after that first
month
it will pull from hbo max and then go
through the standard windowing to
pre you know premium vod to
physical media before eventually making
its way onto
cable normal cable for free um
you're about to see suicide squad
dune matrix four
you know and and it's it is a massive
kind of tectonic
shift in the way we're thinking about
streaming and theatrical
um to the point where when the when the
vaccine news broke
all of the movie theater stock rose
because it was like oh we got a vaccine
maybe we'll be back by you know may june
of next year
um so amc stunks went up you know cinema
stocks went up everybody was feeling you
know a little bit emboldened
and then warner brothers says you know
what we're not sure we believe that
um we're not sure that we believe that
we'll be back in theaters in force we're
not we're not sure we believe that
internationally we'll be back in
theaters the way we were
and so we're going to do this and then
all of those movie theater stocks
start to kind of bottom out a little bit
um
and ultimately again like we talked
about with with with
wonder woman this is a big ass marketing
play
to increase the subscription base for
hbo max
and if you hadn't been thinking about
subscribing before
if wonder woman wasn't enough to get you
to do it maybe tom and jerry will be
if you like kids it may be a denzel
washington movie the little things will
be it if you're horror fan the conjuring
the devil made me do it will be the
thing
if you really liked hamilton in the
heights when manuel miranda's next movie
is coming
like they're hitting every quadrant they
possibly can by giving the thing
you can't get anyplace else for the low
low price of 11.99 a month
this is their big netflix move man
netflix made its big move when it
started being able to offer something
nobody else had
yeah warner brothers right now going
like hold my beer because they're like
here's something
you've not seen before and it's
something that you would go to a movie
theater to see
like now a lot of the movie theaters of
course completely you know
disappointed by this uh or upset or
outraged
with the point being i saw amc go on
like they're leaving
billions on the table when they do this
i don't know if i agree with that i mean
yes perhaps they're leaving billions on
the table
if you were to freeze time but you don't
even if a
vaccine happens in june you're not gonna
get movie theaters full the way we used
to have movie theaters full before the
before the quarantine so warner brothers
looking at like a real
[ __ ] position do we hold our entire
slate until the world goes back
completely to normal which won't be for
like
a year you know what i'm saying so
or do we you know we got the streaming
thing
and we are competing against netflix and
they're spending all the money in the
world
we you know was eventually it goes there
anyway
so how about we use this weird moment in
time this
once in a moment a once-in-a-lifetime
[ __ ] cataclysm
uh at the box office in the industry
to you know try something else doesn't
mean they're going to do it forever but
like i see they really have no choice
you yeah i mean their their press
release puts it very well where they
said
this hybrid model was created as a
strategic response to the impact of the
ongoing global pandemic
that like yeah it's it's it's a somewhat
unique
it's an entirely unique um set of
circumstances that the only
sane response to it is we can't pretend
that we're going back to normal anytime
soon
and we have 18 movies that we put
into production that we have to release
into the world um
because for any number of reasons not
the least of which is we can't suddenly
have this blood of [ __ ] that we're going
to try and pump into the theaters in
2022
like there's no room for anything you
know and and netflix has shown
that you can make money by making 200
million movies and releasing it for free
to your subscribers
you know they do it all the time i don't
know how much mac cost but i'm sure was
expensive
red notice this 200 million dollar rock
ryan reynolds movie
gal gadot is in it too you know 600
grand last year like they
they are in this business of making
giant
movies just for a streamer and so
this doesn't seem like the craziest
thing in the world and every business
will have its time when it has to
drastically reassess
what it is and i feel like for now
movies are hitting where music was
hitting
when napster started when they had to
realize oh
crap suddenly there's an internet
suddenly there's ways for people to get
music in ways that we have not been able
to previously monetize
and don't know how to deal with and like
you have to adjust
or you die and it took music way longer
to adjust than it should have
and movies theatrical especially is
facing that moment which is
we've been doing it this way for a
hundred years and it worked out okay so
far
but now here's this thing and we have to
pivot and adjust
or we're going to die or uh hbo max
i don't think you could just like join
the trial period and watch wonder woman
and then drop the trial like i think
they're making you join up for a period
of time
okay i'm gonna go real quick i never do
this but i have to go to the bathroom
okay keep going i'll keep going um
yeah i mean disney did that when they
they sort of
disbanded the the trial period when
hamilton
um started because they were like listen
we understand that people are gonna do
what they did for
were for hbo for the longest time
because we're signing up for hbo when
the sopranos are on
and we're going to cancel as soon as the
sopranos is off and we're going to keep
on going and so
disney plus was like you know what no
more trial period
right we have the verily's got you for a
month and we will we will rely on
the american consumer's inherent
laziness um
that they will forget to cancel after
that month and that kind of happens and
so i think that
warner brothers is banking similarly on
that same
you know weird eye off the ballness of
the u.s consumer and they're like yeah
we signed up for one
for more hbo max for wonder woman but
we're still doing it
and we get all these other things that's
not so bad
uh now might be a good time to run
through some of our uh donations
yeah let's see who else decided to stand
up to cancer
uh luis torres donated fifty dollars in
memory of my dad
uh uh boba fettish
world of warcraft uh on twitter as he
starts his last round of chemo
uh one of his friends donated to him
noelle fisher donated 50
todd teal donated 50 says thanks for all
you guys do
uh bat man batman ultra seven thanks for
doing this
it means a lot i lost my granddad and
dog to cancer
evan w donated 50
z donated 25 says seriously [ __ ] cancer
uh leo hale just finished chemo versus
stage three cancer we can make it just
keep
plugging along keep your head up uh
pat dyer cancer sucks donating in memory
of
family loss and family and friends
battling
just found out one of my regulars is
battling cancer
um john
abarca fifty dollars donated
um a lot of generous people on our
stream
joel sampson fifty dollars uh vincent l
huge fan of the show
glad to do some good the rosado family
15 bucks god bless stay safe
uh all in the addicted gamblers podcast
dropped a hundred bucks to uh fight
cancer
thank you fellas justin morgan fifty
dollars
let's see uh gil martinez hundred
dollars lost my grandmother to
pancreatic cancer
uh that's amazing that that's you know
this i don't
i am out of words for that level of
generosity you know
just and and i i empathize and
sympathize so much
with people who've lost um loved ones to
cancer i'm blessed that that's never
happened to me but
i have nothing but but uh my heart
my heart is open for all of those folks
yeah i
um my mom passed away from cancer uh
three months after i think we opened
scum and villainy so
yeah she never even got to to come see
it because she was too sick
um and i uh i've told this story in
person but
um scum and villainy was conceived
and announced uh i think the week before
my mom got diagnosed with um lymphoma in
her brain
and so uh that
that was building
that bar and coming up with how we were
going to do it
was done from a um a hospital room in
chicago illinois
with my mom and um
and it was fantastic because it gave me
something
to to do while i
sat there and i mean my mom just got
sicker and sicker and it was
tough you know and it was also tough to
basically move
away from my life here but um
but it's i mean it's a terrible thing
and uh
i it's incredible that everybody is so
generous i think it's an easy
uh nobody loses when you donate
to cure cancer you know i think that's a
uh the villain that we can all be
superheroes to fight yeah
for sure you know cancer is the nazi of
diseases
um it's probably incredibly glib but uh
but it's also we can all agree answer
sucks
nazi suck uh jeremy wein i'm in a good
mood
have some more fight cancer money
another hundred dollars
jesus jeremy um
jamie cat ears oh cat ears hundred
dollars oh jamie
cancer can't be bargained with can't be
reasoned with kyle reese
uh let's see john r
25 i lost my best friend at 22 years old
because of brain cancer
um he loved kevin's films thank you both
for this
uh jay duchaine says fifty dollars for
pops
um calvin e
i lost my aunt and grandfather to cancer
and my mother's in remission doing
what little i can
you guys are doing amazing it's more
than a little for sure
um and it's i mean it's incredible we're
at let's see
4 31
which is awesome we're gonna we may
double our goal
that's unbelievable you guys rock
let's see who else we have um
let's see i'm going through i have we
have 10 pages of
donations bill esposito 50
and memory of liz adams
uh gloria for my dad lost him 10 years
ago
in september i hate cancer uh
franz g a hundred dollars this is the
way
mark anthony sepulveda uh
my sister died from it then my older
brother had it
then my other sister had it then i had
it [ __ ] cancer dude
yeah uh my best friend lost his mom last
year to cancer he was
just diagnosed with the same cancer as
her
uh [ __ ] this disease a hundred dollars
from kevin fandry
sherry donated five dollars as a
five-year cancer survivor
nice nice there's stories you love to
hear
welcome back sir we uh we we just play
off the [ __ ] absence i just
i that hummus went right through me
that's all i'm gonna say
all right kids we uh we are now over 4
600
raising money to stand up to cancer oh
my god i'll go to the bathroom again if
it helps
i'll do it on camera if it'll get us to
5 000.
[Laughter]
what else we got what's in the news um
it seems as if
in addition to uh sort of unzipping
their fly and showing off the entirety
of their 2021 slate
um the snyder cut is coming potentially
earlier than we thought it was
um there was a a blog post
published by warner media's ceo jason
keller
who was talking about the future of hbo
max and uh
he said you know there's a there's so
many amazing hbo original series and max
originals i'm excited about
um a tiger woods documentary series uh
you know stephen soderbergh thing
and then this little thing called zack
snyder's justice league
coming in a few months
in a few months doesn't seem as if it's
october yeah
that's a few to him it's unclear
but uh but but it seems as if it's
coming
potentially sooner than we thought it
was and then again
apparently zach has gone on record
saying that the reshoots will only
constitute about four minutes of new
footage
yeah so there you go i mean so there you
go plus the rest of it has been
assembled for a while right
right so you know it seems as if the
bulk of the
work was rendering cg you know kind of
recutting
recoloring color grading all the stuff
putting his footage back
in taking joss's footage out right so
it's mostly
you know post-production work more than
it is actual new production work
i i think it's actually yeah it's more
old production work than it is
post and new production like you know it
cut represents
all the [ __ ] he shot which they didn't
use
which apparently is enough to turn it
into a two-parter
yeah um so maybe april
maybe march maybe may
but it seems as if it's it's the front
end of the year and not the back end of
the year
which you know in addition to this
bounty of warner brothers goodness
not the worst thing this is how they i
don't know if they beat netflix but
this is how they become neck and neck
with netflix man
who's who would you say the top
streamers are right now netflix then
disney plus
um yeah netflix by a relatively wide
margin netflix is somewhere over 200
million subscribers
um worldwide disney plus i think is only
domestic
um but i think they they're somewhere
around
50 60 65 million and who
is america only what about amazon prime
um amazon prime i'm not sure um i'm
video or whatever
yeah like it's it's odd because the
the subscribers to amazon prime get the
video
but they're not subscribing specifically
for the video right
um so the prime consumers are that's a
massive audience
but i don't know the percentage of those
that actually use the
video service regularly um hbo max
apparently has only 8.6 million accounts
activated
um you know there are another 28 some
odd million
not switched on even though they have
hbo max access because they're at t
customers
or their hbo subscribers um but 8.6
million accounts activated for hbo max
compared to 200 million for netflix
there's a lot of ground they have to
keep up to catch up with so
a giant swing like this seems like it
makes sense for them
um and i don't know if it makes sense
for them but it's [ __ ] sure good for
us
my god man i know some people are like
don't you want to see this on a big
screen
i mean in my case i will watch it on a
big screen i have a
very large television 103 inches some of
them yes i absolutely will miss seeing
on the big screen but
if california or southern california
rather ever opens our movie theaters
i'll have a chance to you know have a
choice at that point to go to one
or the other but um whatever theaters
are open
i i much prefer to watch it here man
that's
that's going to be fantastic i can't
believe we're getting doomed
but i guess they're done we would have
had dune like right now
had there been covered right yeah and so
i don't i don't know when
those movies are going to hit hbo max
you know because
the dates are all a little bit pecocta
as they are anyway
um but [ __ ] it can't wait
can't wait you know and and i think the
what i want as a movie going experience
is the i want to sit in a packed movie
house and watch a movie on opening night
and i don't know when we're going to get
that again um i see a version of
the matinee movie experience where it's
like oh hey it's me and like six other
people in this theater
also not bad also known as the kevin
smith movie experience as well
with other people in a movie theater you
know not not bad i've seen some of my
favorite movies with four other people
in the in the house but like
if i'm gonna go see black widow i kind
of want to be there opening night and
have that feeling of opening night
um and i don't know if you're gonna get
that until 2022
at least not for me so might as well
enjoy him at home
indeed indeed um i applaud them thank
you hbo max
uh you know i know some people i i
wonder what chris nolan thinks
we should ask him yeah there was there
was some
uh everyone always wants to know like
because he's the
like you got to see in the theater so i
wonder if he was mad at them
you know he probably is because it seems
as if
his the grand tenant experiment failed
which is
i see good natured about it though like
in the articles a couple weeks or a week
ago he was like yeah
you know and he was actually he put a
nice he painted a good face on it i
thought but
you know i guess even he has to realize
right now as much as we all love the
theaters
like you know
there's no there's no romance or poetry
or sentimentality um that will prevent
the
[ __ ] coven from entering your lungs
so yeah it's for a minute we don't
movie theater is not the priority and
stuff but i wonder if
if he is like um i mean
there's there's no choice hbo max warren
brothers really had no choice
what were they gonna do just sit there
and [ __ ] every time they put one of
those movies out like
putting tenant out not only was the cost
of making tenant
but it cost them to market tenant which
they did at full pitch
so and their returns as we know were not
nearly
what chris nolan normally does and stuff
so that's with like one of their
strongest weapons
so you know they're not feeling like oh
let's go into battle again let's spend
good bad money after good to try to
sell people come to watch this in a
movie theater
so we can make money the old-fashioned
way you know
like let's use this moment in time to
just
pump this [ __ ] up man maybe the maybe
we'll get
two more subscriptions if they know they
can watch the prequel to sopranos man
the many saints of newark or whatever
it's called that's also one of the
movies that
you get to see so i mean it feels like
yeah pennant was
tenant was a necessary experiment
like jesus of 2020
films man it died for us
and then yes if if we can be
incentivized to stay home and watch
movies
um and not go outside i feel like this
is also
a a net good for society
if there's things for us to do that is
new and different without leaving the
house
what other news we got um we talked i
want to say this last week maybe the
week before
my my long-standing envy of oscar isaac
and the way he looks and uh
what his experience must be like in the
world he is going to star
in a new sony video game adaptation
called metal gear solid playing snake uh
solid solid snake
i was doing it his name as you know the
teacher goes down the list
is there a blockage the eggs showing
mark could you tell that i
don't know anything about this subject
it was a little bit but that's all good
this is a video game movie in the video
game movie baseball
not [ __ ] stop trying to make this
video game a video game into a movie has
it been successful yet
um tomb raider those movies did
relatively well
um
detective pikachu you know there's
there's
there's
a handful of them that that have done
you know
creed assassins creed not less
less so um but yeah super mario bros
the classic classic and now they're
doing that game that you like that
yeah the last of us yeah that's as a
series though that's in the series
so yeah i mean this game has been in
various iterations since
96 and it's always followed snake a
soldier who infiltrates a nuclear
weapons facility to neutralize the
terrorist threat from foxhound
it's it's it's this weird insane mostly
cut scene built game that was one of the
first to introduce stealth as a gameplay
mode
um what's exciting though is jordan
roberts who did
kong skull island is directing um
and uh and yeah sony sony is
bound and determined to make movies out
of their
video games they're making uncharted
with tom holland they're doing this with
oscar isaac um so yeah
you know like it but it's oscar isaac so
i'll go
i want them to make uh my favorite video
games into a movie
yeah nhl no
uh combat from atari 2600
pitfall pitfalls such an easy make
combat it's just two tanks
i'd watch that [ __ ] movie two tanks
trying to kill each other on an island
that would be badass brad pitt was in a
movie with one tank and it was really
good by david
david ayers who tanks in a movie you got
two times the movie that that
[Laughter]
[Music]
um i think he's hiding behind the wall
sir he can't possibly be
no i'm pretty sure he's hiding behind
that wall there's only eight walls sir
he's got to be behind one of them
shoot the wall then ricochet the shot
what uh what other news um
busy man oscar isaac i mean his [ __ ]
list of to do [ __ ] is insane
he's in scene for a marriage opposite
jessica's chastain he's starring in moon
knight eventually for disney
he'll be in um doom um
any moment now
he's gonna star in and produce the great
machine um based on ex machina the brian
k vaughan book
and he's in francis in the godfather
with jake gyllenhaal
um oh that's right he's playing uh he's
playing uh
uh francis ford coppola right yeah like
he's got the fullest dance card
of any drop dead gorgeous guatemalan
you've ever met
he's got the [ __ ] chops to match he's
a great actor um
abra duvernay is uh staying in the dc
comics business
um she's currently working on um new
gods
um as a feature she's directing the
miniseries
dmz based on the vertical book and now
she is uh doubling down tripling down
um with naomi which is based on a brian
cave uh
no brian michael bendis another brian um
and david walker's dc comic book um
about a teen girl who journeys from her
small northwestern town to the heights
of the multiverse
when a supernatural event shakes her
hometown to the core
naomi sets out to encourage origins and
what she discovers will challenge
everything we believe about our heroes
now when you say our heroes are they the
dc
heroes um they are the dc heroes this is
a this is a straight-up dcu book
so you know this is another sort of
brick
in the road the cw is building to both
youthify and diversify
their uh their cw superhero programming
wait this is a cw show this is a cw show
i thought you were saying it's a feature
you know cw that sounds very right up
cw's alley
totally i mean they have wonder girl
coming um
and they have you know the black
lightning spinoff painkiller
and then they still have you know
batwoman
and you know supergirl and flash are
still kind of going but supergirl is on
her last season but
finishes this year flash just still gone
for what we know
yeah and uh legends yeah i think
this might be the year i mean you know
maybe they call
quits on legends i don't know yeah i
mean it's
one of those things where you chose
always we've talked about this before
show's always
there's this crossing point when a show
goes from
being like new and cheap too old and
expensive and the ratings tend to go
down instead of up and the price tends
to go up instead of down
they may be point right about now they
might be at the point where not like
w in two years we'll have a completely
new slave
that does i mean what we've been
accustomed to for many years now
yeah networks are a lot like sport
franchises which like we start we have
our great run
we have all of our all-star players we
made a push for the championship we want
it great yay and then it's a rebuilding
phase where it's all those guys were too
expensive
and their contracts were up and then we
had to rebuild an entire team from
scratch
all this is this is going to be the 2024
cw
all new faces all new all new stories
um and it's exciting i mean as much as
i'm i
i loathe to see things like flash and
supergirl go
like the new is always really enticing
and also
they ain't going well flash is certainly
going nowhere except to the big screen
and [ __ ]
yeah but you know there's gonna there's
gonna get to the point where like
grant will be too expensive um for them
to justify with the ratings so that'll
be like all right
flash season nine is the last season and
we're gonna go out with a bang
um yeah
it makes sense i guess but it's a bummer
to watch the shows i mean this must
when when they you know said hey this is
the last season for supergirl i was like
oh this is what all those
people who liked arrow felt like when
arrow was done and stuff
um the notion of like but why does it
have to stop
um one day that'll happen with flash as
well it will
you know but but the the good thing
seems to be that these shows get to end
on their own terms
they get to sort of you know call the
shot into the bleachers and say you know
what we have
10 more episodes left of this to do we
got 50 more episodes to do
we can wrap up this story in a way that
feels good and right and appropriate for
us and for our audience
in ways that are far less tragic than oh
we just canceled it like oh we're just
not doing anymore it's like yeah but you
got a clue hanger yep sorry
yeah it's done we don't have any money
guess what happened
we can't make this happen anymore yeah
that's so [ __ ]
um do we have any news about the marvel
shows
um the only news that there was about
them all the shows was that
a um the 15th of january allegedly for
one division
um that uh that natasha romanov's
sister elena i believe from the movie
black widow
um might be appearing in other shows
namely
hawkeye and then the uh
winter soldier and that there's now
official still footage from the hawkeye
tv show
showing hayley steinfeld as kate bishop
and
lucky pete the pizza dog and
the debut of echo who doesn't care
that uh david mack and joe cassata
created
hmm the death the deaf character
so he's in the show as well man they're
pulling other characters
from the marvel universe yeah i mean i
i she like i think david mack was the
one that followed me and
um on daredevil with joe so i think
she's been around the character for like
20 years
that was back in 1998. um but that's
gotta be exciting for
david mack to be like holy [ __ ] they're
taking my character he's cool
he's like i'd rather have the check he's
a sweet guy such a talented artist
um yeah man that show just
suddenly got me way the [ __ ] interested
when it's like oh they are doing
the kate bishop story that we all know
like yeah
i mean yeah yay i applaud that rather
than being like
let's do our own hawkeye thing like no
no do that
because everyone likes that do the matte
production hawkeye we love them
no complaints go go
um and the last story of the week is um
we had talked last week week before week
before that i don't remember
um miller and lord were tackling a
universal monster with channing and
tatum
um universal you're trying to guess what
that monster was
right we're like who's it gonna be well
it's not gonna be the mummy because
they're probably gonna stick clear with
the mummy for a little bit invisible man
they already did
probably gonna do more of that um
um creatures black lagoon they're
probably not gonna touch but they might
who the hell knows
um but what is clear is that james juan
um
mm-hmm there's a conjuring directed
aquaman
aquaman too um is uh
is making a van helsing movie
uh van helsing when we last saw him was
played by hugh jackman
yeah in a piece of stuff alone adventure
movie that they did
some years ago yeah um but yeah james
juan is sort of uh producing it
the guy who made overlord fellaini
julius avery is directing
um he's [ __ ] hyper kinetic man
yeah yeah it's pretty [ __ ] dope
because again
nazis always good to be punching the
nazis yeah yeah
um and so yeah it's a universal is
for real getting into their universal
monsters business
in a surprisingly interesting way you
know
because the the less interesting way was
the tom cruise mummy which was
let's just build this weird monster
universe the dark universe
and try and connect it with all of these
things even though it might not be
working even though nobody seems to care
even though
tom cruise isn't the mummy um until
spoilers the very end of the movie
um but nobody seemed to want that
version of it and instead they seem to
be doing this kind of loose collection
of filmmakers who are all interesting
making movies that
just happen to feature universal
monsters but are also
way more um socially relevant and way
more contemporary
than just let's do some mummy i'm
telling him
if the the they set a high bar with the
invisible man
yeah yeah but it's such a smart movie
it's such a smart move and not expensive
either man
like you know i'd like to see them
continue that
just you know forces them to be more
clever and [ __ ] then you
won't get something like the tom cruise
mummy which is like well they spent a
lot of money doing this
why are we doing this i'm clear [ __ ]
up look how [ __ ] up this is oh my god
he's wearing a [ __ ] suit that makes
him invisible it's just [ __ ] up
um so so boy they're moving on their
new monster universe they're moving and
it's super smart because if you can make
these things for i mean i think
invisible man was like 12
somewhere between 12 to 15 million and
made 130 million
back globally the invisible man yeah
i remember correctly it was under 10.
i've i've heard as low as 7 million
bucks
at which point i was like are you
kidding me that was only 2 million
dollars more than mall rats
i got to go back to work but if that's
their model if that's their pattern
we're like yeah we'll give you anywhere
under 20 million dollars do whatever the
[ __ ] you want that's right
reinvent the story let's do everyone
just gotta keep the name and the idea
yeah like if you can do that because i
remember hearing
um fx used to work this way um they may
still
but back when they were talking about um
the louis show
and featuring he who shall not be named
that
that that landgraf the guy runs
fx was like we don't pay them enough to
interfere with them
we offered them raises but they were
like well if you want to
if you if we take this races i mean you
get to give us notes she says well yes
and then i want to raise
just let me make the show i want to make
and if this is the same thing it's like
yeah
if we do this for seven million dollars
we can do whatever we want
then i don't need 20 i don't need 30.
like that makes you more interested in
what i do that makes you more invested
in what i do
i can skip it under the wire and do
whatever the [ __ ] seems interesting to
me and i can chase whatever dragon i
want
i'll do that and so maybe that's the
miller lord
frankenstein i'll say it i think i think
they're making a friend you think it's
making a friend
very
monster really yeah
you know if it's if it's me it's not me
but uh
but if you get like one of people's
sexiest men alive
into a horror movie then you can also
make that horror movie this commentary
on
the the modern and american fascination
with beauty
and surgery and you know artificial
beautification and what happens if you
take that too far
what happens if it's not and even if
they keep the like he's sewn together
from the parts of other dead people man
a minute he channel could be the [ __ ]
head
yeah and then the rest of them could be
like other people's body parts and [ __ ]
but like wearing a shirt you'd never
know but then he's like
yeah and you're like ah he's a packwork
man underneath
or if it's if it's frankenstein is also
frankincense monster
if you do something where it's a guy
who's like disfigured and hideous and
ugly
who starts cutting on himself to make
himself beautiful
and starts grafting on body parts
that is brilliant
shut the [ __ ] up stop
giving away go oh my god that's so
[ __ ] good man
hey universal dear universal studios
this guy down there bill they'll [ __ ]
write
this [ __ ] yeah this that guy
that's a great idea um all right that's
all the news that's all the news brother
jc it's time for you to hit the stage
give us an update how are we doing 5
256 so we've more than doubled it
wow congratulations kids and thank you
the good folks that stand up
cancer thank you as well man
uh well done everybody for a quiet
saturday night at home we got a lot
accomplished and [ __ ]
but we're not done no we got three
three questions that we're going to take
from you
the audience and jc to make it fair he's
going to be the guy that picks jc
what do they want to know all right uh
jude was
interested in knowing what background
star wars character
and they're talking like deep background
they're saying like
will roe hood or elon sleaze bagano
uh will row hood being the ice cream
maker guy in the orange suit from cloud
city and
elan sleeves bagano is the death stix
guy
uh would kevin mark like to see on
the mandalorian lobot
give me you know who'd still
well no biggs died in star wars right
i want lobot
he's an unsung hero you could do a whole
robot episode like the boba fett episode
where you're like
ultimate badass bald guy in his
headphones and [ __ ]
um how about you mark
i'm just trying to imagine the bald guy
in headphones show
um well it doesn't have to be a show he
just says gets pop up on the mandalorian
right he usually gets to pop up in the
middle yeah he gets like an
episode you know i mean after lando left
cloud city it was held by
well the empire held it right they were
leaving people there but then
leia chased them off i guess
and then vader said prepare my ship and
then they all left
so did he leave a garrison behind
in cloud city or no i mean it seems like
you know
[ __ ] lobot gets a battlefield
promotion for certainly he's
administrator of cloud city
like the other guy just [ __ ] left i'm
the only one with the keys
i'm the one who knows where everything
is why don't
i run it and he's just like and he
[ __ ] runs the company the same way he
behaved an empire he's like when he
needs something done he just goes
and everybody [ __ ] moves and
uh they're like do you want to talk now
sir and he's like
and that's it yes he's he's the og
he went to [ __ ] bespin in the
mandalorian right that'd be dope
why not go there to see slave one land
on the same landing pad that it was
investment
or what if uh what if the cloud city
crashed
like what if what drop the planet below
yeah and so you just see the husk the
wreckage of cloud city
and then there's nobody crawls out of it
and he's like i'm okay
everyone's fine here i'm here for the
last movie everybody
um i go uh who do you go i go
nice the lady who's in charge the
original
general leia the original lady general
of the the rebellion um i think there's
the
you know the super the the the helen
mirren version of manmothma
who's kind of been keeping [ __ ] held
together on the outer rim you know
maybe that's where leia is maybe that's
where you know
she's she's the moses to leia's
uh david you know we're like david's got
a [ __ ] all right you were the war
hero before and i gotta pick up then
carry the
the mantle and it's it's from mon mothma
that that leia learns how to be a
general
man mothma is from the planet chandrala
which in the episode where the uh
baby yoda goes to school the
protocol droid mentions the seat of the
republic
is now on chandrala so maybe
her home planet mm-hmm because she was
in charge of the rebellion when the
rebels beat the empire so she would be
like
president or whatever the [ __ ] yeah
bring it home
um that's good uh you know another story
i would like to do or
i i don't know if you can get a whole
episode yes all right
so they go to endor
and you know there's whatever's going on
for the [ __ ] a story
the b story is uh
mando meets this uh like
like uber depressed old ewok
who's just no joy [ __ ]
drinks too much and [ __ ] like that he
can't
speak ewokies but like you know he's got
that translator droid or whatever [ __ ]
and you find out that this was the
leewok
from return of the jedi when him and his
buddy are running and they get there's a
blast
and then he gets up and he tries to get
his buddies like come on come on and
then his buddy's dead and he lays there
he's like oh it's his story he's like he
has all this survivors of guilt that
he's lived with for a long time
maybe he hires mando to kill him
[Laughter]
i want you to kill him he's like i can't
deal with this [ __ ] anymore man
i lived he died he was a better ewok
like i shaved all my hair because i
can't be an ewok anymore yeah he's one
of them baldy walks like the bald cats
you ain't even got to go to endor for
that he's in some bar
on some desert like why are you so small
and oddly patchy and kind of
bald and i left i lost my hair
i lost my pride johnny's got his hair
johnny's got his pride put a little moon
stuck in there
nice they call me raisin look at me
great question thank you
uh next one z howard 1992
uh for kevin what fictional character
would you like to get high with
and for mark what fictional character
would you like to get drunk with
i i'm a loner stoner man like i don't
really
get together with people and smoke
because generally when i smoke i'm
doing like i'm writing or i'm being
creative that was a deal i made with
myself long ago if you're going to smoke
you got to do something creative at the
same time so generally speaking like i'm
i don't
i've never really smoked with people and
not because i'm like
like oh [ __ ] people just cause um it's
not
like the only the only times i smoke
when like people are around
or when we're in the alleyway before the
show
um doing batman beyond when we're when
we're scumming villainy
and like i'll have a smoke either before
or after generally before the show
but and and it's not like they're all
joining me i'm just smoking by myself
but like i don't i don't think of that
as something
that i do with others that being said
who would i like to get stoned with
i mean there's part of me that's like
i'd like to get stoned with my own
characters but at the same time like
you know i i know all jay schtick
um and silent bob doesn't seem that
interesting
um let me see who would i like to get
high with
batman
soften him up a bit maybe that's all
that's been missing
all this time part of healing
you know isn't just beating up
[ __ ] muggers and chain snatchers and
[ __ ] like that part of healing
is you know therapeutic medically
therapeutic
so i'd like to get high with batman oh
my god that'd be amazing
how often do you think your parents for
real
do you ever go down that alley or just
not like allies anymore
all the time you've been fighting crime
did you ever have to kick someone's ass
in crime allen if you did did you beat
them a little more severely
[Laughter]
um how about you who do you want to get
drunk
who do i want to get drunk with i feel
like you want to get drunk with somebody
for whom the night will ultimately
become
unpredictable in ways that you uh you
were not prepared for
so i feel as if um
bigby from trainspotting
um robert carla that guy that guy
and nuts i'm not gonna let you hang out
with that guy he said nobody [ __ ]
leaves until
we find a cult what did it like
nobody wants that guy around a good time
although
super fun to watch that guy be around
like you don't want to actually like
be necessarily associated with him you
just kind of want to be with him when he
goes off somewhere
just you can watch the explosion i'll be
there with my
my stoner buddy batman cleaning up your
[ __ ] mess he's like
hanging out with the makeupless joker
for heaven's sake
you can disarm him in seven ways like
how would you do it batman
that's what hurt the most deep cuts pull
mark
you know not even like not even like
renton you went for bigby
but he like he wouldn't he was the one
that didn't like the heroin
he's like i'll put that shot in my body
and then he was drinking liquor instead
yes it was either going to be bigby or
uh or
deluca from pretty woman because i feel
like she's a riot
[ __ ] uh laura sin giacomo
what do you want a [ __ ] late 80s kick
where where you're pulling is there
wow man i thought i heard a dog's age
um good good obscure polls
not genre in any way yeah not at all
like a bunch of our audience is like
pretty what uh what now i remember that
movie used to be huge
no it's massive so big um all right
jc that's two i don't smoke but if i
did if i had to choose i would choose
bender from the breakfast club
to get high with sure but he's he's a
troublemaker too he's going to get you
in trouble man
no trouble get out of superman that'd be
amazing
you'd be like now let's get real high
and he picks you up and you're like go
flying and [ __ ]
my mind
you read my mind [ __ ] you i can't read
your mind he's like i can read your mind
you saw the [ __ ] movie
jc what is our last question even uh our
last question
is from nicholas gonzalez i do not
believe there's any relation to nate
gonzalez
um forget by nate's book smartest in
residence
uh what wants to know the top
three christmas movies of all time
okay all time i guess we should do
separate lists
um and and is this what i personally
feel or what i consider would be for the
world
i think your favorite so i can leave
miracle on 34th street off this [ __ ]
yeah
yeah christmas story
scrooged and what's my wild card slot
die hard you
um and not that order necessarily those
are my three
the movies that i feel i need to watch
every year or it's not christmas um
die hard is on that list for sure
um it's a wonderful life is on that list
you still watch that movie
i do yeah i do because it's so
[ __ ] dark it is so much darker than
it gets credit for being
you know especially if you imagine that
everything happens afterwards because
yeah he committed suicide on that bridge
so this is this is his version of heaven
that's true um
and you know i i it's not a movie
it's 28 minutes long but how the grinch
stole christmas
um the dr seuss the chuck jones animated
version
um i don't want any movie of it like
i you know and i saw the cumberbatch i
saw that i saw the mojo movie and it's
pretty good
um it was just uh like in the top 10 on
netflix like for the last two or three
weeks i saw i was happy for
yeah um but the emoji only had half an
hour to fill versus 90 minutes yeah
and i was super surprised i saw like
runner up
um this movie clouts this animated movie
that was on netflix i think premiered
last year
oh yeah yeah it was like 70 75 minutes
long
yeah um but really adorable and this
really interesting just kind of
reframing of the santa claus
myth um i found it kind of enchanting so
so yeah
yeah those are the ones scrooged man i i
can watch scrooge once a month every
month
like his i try to live my life like bill
murray
like bill murray's character in the last
10 minutes of scrooge
particularly the last five minutes of
scrooge like [ __ ]
that speech that he gives uh
on camera like on air to camera
is so awesome and moving like and
it it it's it's honestly it's like you
know it's [ __ ] goofy take off on
the christmas carol and stuff but it's
one of my favorite films about
redemption of all time like it's just
incredibly moving to me and hysterically
funny even after all these times of
watching it
bill murray is so [ __ ] good even
though that movie was i saw that movie
in high
school uh even though i saw the movie
back then it still
like holds up today even dopey little
[ __ ] that i never
like thought was all that funny when i
was younger until i understood more of
life like at one point
like his old boss shows up like jacob
marley lou
um his name is and he's the one telling
him like you've gotta
[ __ ] change your ways you're gonna be
visited by three ghosts
and he puts frank cross like through the
window and he's hanging him out there
and he's like please don't don't pick up
a suicide
that just [ __ ] kills me each and
every time she was like dangling
whole being held by a [ __ ] ghost of
his dead boss and he's still worried
about like what people will think that
in my i still love his reaction when
they're like uh
the newspaper comes in he goes ooh who's
that she's pretty she's like this old
woman died last night after watching
your show and he's like
this is incredible like it turns it into
joy
that speech at the end man that's
everything to me
so good and christmas story
i love those books if you've never read
[ __ ] gene shepherd and you like
christmas story do yourself a favor he
wrote short stories they were personal
essays
so you're never really pot committed for
longer than like 10 pages
and they're all just like the narration
of the christmas story
which was narrated by gene shepard
himself
i was going to say the soundtrack to my
holiday season
and the movie that i have to watch is
a charlie brown christmas it's not crazy
apple you must have apple tv now to do
that
they um they let it air on pbs
they actually retract it and they let it
air on pbs
um cbs was the home of that for my
entire
childhood man and i as a kid
for the first i would say 17 18 maybe 20
years of my life
i watched it every single year because
well probably not because we got cable
at a certain point and then vhs tapes
so let's say for the first 12 13 years
of my life
i for sure watched it while it aired
because we didn't have like oh they're
going to rerun it
next week it's like no they'll they'll
rerun it next year so either you see it
now or you don't see it and [ __ ]
those days are gone man now it's just
like you know at one point i was like oh
i want to watch sorry live and i was
like
go do your show you can watch it [ __ ]
afterwards like on youtube
it'll be there yeah so you live in an
on-demand world kid
uh i wanted to say uh for anybody who
didn't watch this live who's gonna be
watching it
over i think the course of the next week
our donation link which is in the
description will be
active for another i think until
december
11th or december 16th i believe
so uh you're still able to donate uh on
through the uh fat man beyond link to
stand up to cancer if you're watching
this
saturday thank you to everybody who
donated
tonight while we were watching the show
doing the show
uh live uh you know we were
hoping to get to 2 500 bucks but you
guys let us down and went way beyond
that
heavens man uh please don't do that too
often people will think we might be able
to do some good in this world
but it wasn't us it was all you we're
just the two dudes who
talked a lot about the mandalorian yes
that's what we do that's that's our job
in life
is to appreciate the [ __ ] finer
things man
that's the way this is goddamn the way
did you have a good time tonight kids
did you stand up to cancer a little bit
tonight kids
we all did man uh if you had a good time
i'll tell you right now
there would have been no good time at
all had i
we not had this dude who literally
single-handedly held the show
so i could go take a [ __ ] so give it up
for single-handed mark bernardin ladies
no thank you
jc was a was a was an able body in that
uh time of need
for all people he was uh he was reading
down some of the great donors
give it up for uh jc who gives us a show
to actually do
puts all these diodes and wires together
so we can get out to you even when we're
not there at the scum and villainy
cantina
um thank you so much for watching
uh coming back week after week
means the absolute world kids i got a
lot of in case anyone's wondering i have
like
incredible indigestion tonight i'm sorry
dude does paprika is that make people
[ __ ] like burpee paprika not like
harsh right in terms of a spice
not really it's i mean it's potent but
not
not crazy it's relatively mild
something's been like really giving me
some acid reflux
thank you for being patient through my
tums eating as well
we'll do this again uh next week
maybe uh when are you going to minnesota
i gotta go yeah that's right i'll be out
there uh the 12th
is when uh movies opens up and i cut the
ribbon and stuff like that
so maybe would be the 13th or 14th maybe
a week from tomorrow we'll do a show
excellent
there it is man um thanks for hanging
out with us tonight kids
thanks to everyone who donated to to
stand up to cancer
um our streaming uh partner uh for this
week
and uh come back next week man we'll
talk about a lot of geeky things man
indeed beyond i am kevin smith and i am
mark bernardin
tune in next time same fat time same
fat channel smodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith
for the good of all cree this is the way
you